This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, providing results-driven treatment for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28 who are struggling with mental health issues and co-occurring disorders, including tech-related issues like gaming disorder and social media addiction. Newport's programs take into account the significant impact of technology on the developing brain and support young people to develop healthier relationships with their devices. Learn more at Newport Healthcare.com. Over the past couple of decades, our devices have become our constant companions. About 85% of Americans now own a smartphone, up from just 35% a decade ago, and more than 70% of us are on at least one social media site, according to the Pew Research Center. These days, old friends are more likely to catch up with each other's news via social media or a text message rather than a phone call or a chat over.
本期节目由 Newport Healthcare 赞助，为 12 至 28 岁、正在与心理健康问题和共患病（包括游戏障碍和社交媒体成瘾等科技相关问题）作斗争的青少年和年轻人提供注重结果的治疗。Newport 的项目充分考虑了科技对发育中的大脑的重大影响，并支持年轻人与电子设备建立更健康的联系。了解更多信息请访问 Newport Healthcare.com。在过去的几十年里，我们的设备已经成为我们形影不离的伴侣。据皮尤研究中心称，大约 85% 的美国人现在拥有智能手机，而十年前这一比例仅为 35%；超过 70% 的人至少使用一个社交媒体网站。如今，老朋友们更有可能通过社交媒体或短信来了解彼此的近况，而不是打电话或
coffee. Work meetings have moved to Zoom, and for some of us, that change may be permanent. More and more we live in a digital, virtual world. How has this move to digital communication changed people's relationship with technology and our relationships with each other? How has conversation itself changed in the digital age, and how to computers and artificial intelligence affect how we think about other people, or even what it means to be human? Do we use our devices, or do they use us? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
喝咖啡聊天。工作会议已经转移到了 Zoom，对我们中的一些人来说，这种转变可能是永久性的。我们越来越多地生活在一个数字化的虚拟世界中。向数字通信的转变如何改变了人们与科技的关系以及我们彼此之间的关系？在数字时代，对话本身发生了怎样的变化，计算机和人工智能又如何影响我们对其他人的看法，甚至是“身为人类”意味着什么？是我们使用设备，还是设备使用我们？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Sherry Turkle, a professor in the program in science, technology, and society at the Massachusetts Institute of Technology and Founding Director of the MIT Initiative
探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是雪莉·特克（Sherry Turkle）博士，她是麻省理工学院科学、技术与社会项目教授，也是麻省理工学院
on Technology and Self. She received a joint doctorate in Sociology and personality psychology from Harvard University and is a licensed psychologist. Dr. Terkel has spent more than four decades studying people's relationships with technology, especially computers. She is the author of several best-selling books, including reclaiming conversation, The Power of Talk in a Digital Age, Alone Together, Why We Expect More from Technology and Less from Each Other, and The Second Self, Computers and the Human Spirit. Her newest book, The Empathy Diaries, a memoir, ties together.
科技与自我计划的创始主任。她获得了哈佛大学社会学和人格心理学的联合博士学位，并且是一名注册心理学家。特克博士花了一个多世纪（注：原文如此）的时间研究人们与科技（尤其是计算机）的关系。她是多本畅销书的作者，包括《恢复对话：数字时代谈话的力量》（Reclaiming Conversation: The Power of Talk in a Digital Age）、《在一起孤独：我们对科技的期望更多，对彼此的期望更少》（Alone Together: Why We Expect More from Technology and Less from Each Other）以及《第二自我：计算机与人类精神》（The Second Self, Computers and the Human Spirit）。她的最新书《共情日记》（The Empathy Diaries，一部回忆录）将
her personal story of uncovering family secrets with her research on technology and empathy. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Turkle. It's my pleasure. So you've been studying people's relationships with computers since the 1970s. You were at MIT at the dawn of the personal computer. You've written about how that gave you a glimpse of the future that few people had at that time. Given that experience, what, if anything, has surprised you about where we have ended up today in terms of our relationship. with computers? It's a great question. I think what surprised me is that we have so much evidence of
她揭开家庭秘密的个人故事与她关于科技和共情的研究联系在了一起。非常感谢您今天能做客我们的节目，特克博士。这是我的荣幸。那么，您自 20 世纪 70 年代以来就一直在研究人们与计算机的关系。个人电脑诞生时您就在麻省理工学院。您曾写过，这让您得以一窥当时极少数人能够看到的未来。鉴于这段经历，关于我们在与计算机的关系方面最终走到了今天这一步，有什么（如果有的话）让您感到惊讶吗？这是一个很好的问题。我认为让我惊讶的是，我们有如此多的证据表明
harm, and yet we are barreling on. It's as though we refuse to see the evidence before our eyes and in our hearts of how technology has eroded empathy, how it's assaulted empathy, how we look at our phones and not at each other, we text rather than talk. There's been an assault on conversation. Our children are less likely to be willing to sit at a dinner table and talk to us. And yet we, there's been an assault, certainly, on privacy. We all know that. We fear that. And yet we listen to tech gurus tell us about going into the metaverse.
存在危害，然而我们却在勇往直前。这就好像我们拒绝看到摆在眼前和心中的证据——科技是如何侵蚀共情的，它是如何攻击共情的，我们如何看着手机而不是彼此，我们发短信而不是交谈。对话遭受了攻击。我们的孩子更不愿意坐在餐桌旁和我们说话。然而，隐私肯定也遭受了攻击。我们都知道这一点。我们对此感到恐惧。然而，我们却听信科技大咖们向我们讲述进入元宇宙的事情。
And, you know, we listen to this. And, you know, we say, oh, yeah, the metaverse, maybe that's the next big thing. So I'm kind of surprised, although I guess I'm becoming hardened. And, you know, I mean, I don't want to seem like a Pollyanna or someone very naive. But there has been a great deal of evidence that we have launched ourselves over and over again in technology dreams that have turned out not to be really in our human interest. And yet we seem ready to relaunch. And as someone who's been, you know, a part of that technology criticism, you know, I don't want to say I'm surprised that nobody's paid attention to me. But there have been many technology critics, many great psychologists, many great theorists and researchers who, you know, it's not me and me alone.
而且，你知道，我们听着这些。然后，你知道，我们会说，哦，是的，元宇宙，也许那是下一个重大趋势。所以我有点惊讶，尽管我想我正在变得麻木。而且，你知道，我的意思是，我不想显得像个乐观得盲目的人或者非常天真的人。但是有大量的证据表明，我们一次又一次地投身于那些最终证明并不真正符合我们人类利益的科技梦想中。然而我们似乎准备好再次投身其中。作为一个参与过那种技术批判的人，你知道，我不想说我对没有人关注我感到惊讶。但有许多技术批评家，许多伟大的心理学家，许多伟大的理论家和研究人员，你知道，不是我一个人。
This isn't about me, me, me, this is about many people, a cohort of scientists and social scientists and philosophers who really have. have written about, you know, take a look around. And yet we seem to not be attending to the depreciation of the world. You know, I mean, that's a long answer to a short question. But I do think it's time for a kind of red light. And I'm not, you know, and I'm still working on this problem. But I am surprised that we haven't done better at slowing the pace. Well, you just mentioned the metaverse a moment ago, and I'm just wondering, I mean, since that looks to be maybe the next new thing, are we, like, in effect, building a new reality? Is that possible? I mean, reality is what it is, I guess, but it just seems like we're trying to run away from where we live in a three-dimensional world and go to this other place, which will somehow,
这不是关于我、我、我，这是关于许多人，一群科学家、社会科学家和哲学家，他们真的。写过关于，你知道的，看看周围。然而我们似乎并没有关注这个世界的贬值。你知道，我的意思是，这是一个简短问题的长答案。但我确实认为现在是亮起某种红灯的时候了。而且我不是，你知道的，而且我仍在研究这个问题。但我确实惊讶于我们在放慢步伐方面做得还不够好。好吧，你刚才提到了元宇宙，我在想，既然这看起来可能是下一个新事物，我们是否实际上在构建一个新的现实？这可能吗？我的意思是，现实就是它本来的样子，我想，但它只是看起来我们正试图逃离我们生活的三维世界，去到这个其他地方，它某种程度上会，
be more perfect? Yeah. I mean, the metaverse. I mean, in my book, Life on the Screen, was a 1995 book that really tried to document the first generation of Metaverse
更加完美？是的。我的意思是，元宇宙。我的意思是，我的书《屏幕上的生活》（Life on the Screen）是 1995 年出版的一本试图记录第一代元宇宙的书。
was the first time that people built virtual worlds, the first generation of metaverse-like spaces, where people could go and live in virtual communities, create avatars, create sets,
那是人们第一次构建虚拟世界，是第一代类似元宇宙的空间的第一次，人们可以在那里生活在虚拟社区中，创建头像，创建场景，
second selves where they were thinner and... And taller and younger. Well, they were always taller and thinner and better looking. And, I mean, two or one. Often they were of a different gender. And I thought it was interesting when I tried to say some interesting things about how there was a sense of identity play, which I thought that was very psychologically interesting. I called them identity workshops.
他们更瘦、更高的“第二自我”。而且……更高、更年轻。好吧，他们总是更高、更瘦、长得更好看。而且，我的意思是，二选一。通常他们的性别也不同。我觉得这很有趣，当我试图表达一些有趣的观点，关于有一种身份游戏的感觉时，我认为这在心理学上非常有趣。我称它们为身份工作坊。
I used the work of Erickson on identity play. to say, you know, to try to make a psychological contribution to the good things that could happen when people have other spaces to explore identity in. The trouble was, is that when you live in a parallel life and in not real space, the things that happen in real space that are important don't happen, which is that the friction, the conversation, the needing to negotiate, the fact that people become ill, the fact that we deal with strife and war and need to argue, learn to argue and make peace with one another. You know, in the metaverse, you just walk away.
我借用了埃里克森关于身份游戏的作品。来说明，你知道，试图为当人们有其他空间来探索身份时可能发生的好事做出心理学贡献。问题在于，当你过着平行生活而不是在真实空间中时，真实空间中那些重要的事情就不会发生，也就是说，摩擦、对话、需要协商、人们会生病这一事实、我们处理冲突和战争并需要争论、学会争论并彼此言和的事实。你知道，在元宇宙中，你只要走开就行了，
you don't learn to negotiate. You don't learn to, you know, to have the complex life and the complex love that are the things we really need to live a better life and now more than ever before. In this country, certainly, we need to learn how to talk to people we don't agree with. In the metaverse, we can just silo ourselves and that's what's happened. people choose the community in the metaverse where they agree with everyone around them. So one of the things that troubles me about the move to the metaverse is that, you know, we know what's happened online is that people have chosen the metaverse where everybody around them agrees with them.
你学不会协商。你学不会，你知道，去拥有那些过上更好生活真正需要的复杂生活和复杂的爱，而且现在比以往任何时候都更加需要。在这个国家，当然，我们需要学习如何与我们不同意的人交谈。在元宇宙中，我们可以把自己孤立起来，而这正是已经发生的事情。人们在元宇宙中选择那些周围每个人都与他们意见一致的社区。所以，让我对转向元宇宙感到困扰的事情之一是，你知道，我们知道线上发生的事情是，人们选择了周围每个人都同意他们的元宇宙。
And we've siloed ourselves in places where we don't have to really develop these habits of dealing with community and dealing with friction. You know, cyberspace can be a friction-free world. It's almost the ideal of what it's good for. And what happens in virtual community is that people tend and trend to go to places where there is no friction where you're with people where you, you don't need to have that quality of the real. That's very, very troubling because that's, exactly what we don't need. So harm is not just that people forget how to be empathic. Harm is also that people don't learn the skills of confronting themselves and confronting other people and learning how to compromise. And, you know, and also what is this desire to kind of leave
我们将自己孤立在不必真正培养处理社区和摩擦习惯的地方。你知道，网络空间可以是一个无摩擦的世界。它几乎是其优势的理想状态。而在虚拟社区中，发生的情况是人们倾向于并趋向于去那些没有摩擦的地方，在那里你和与你志同道合的人在一起，你不需要具备现实的那种品质。这非常非常令人不安，因为这正是我们不需要的。所以危害不仅仅是人们忘记了如何去共情。危害还在于人们没有学会面对自己、面对他人以及学习如何妥协的技能。而且，你知道，还有这种渴望想要离开
earth. I mean, tech billionaires want to get on rocket chips and they want to play more complicated games and they want to go to virtual realities. But, you know, we have a world on fire. We have a literally we have a world on fire. And I think the habit of mind where you want to create an artificial world and artificial spaces instead of dealing with the very troubled earth we have here as is one we need to really cast a very cool light on. I don't think that cyberspace has put us, I'm a great believer in all the great things you can do in cyberspace, but I don't think it's put us in good habits of mind
地球。我的意思是，科技亿万富翁们想要坐上火箭，他们想要玩更复杂的游戏，他们想要进入虚拟现实。但是，你知道，我们有一个水深火热的世界。我们字面意义上有一个水深火热的世界。我认为这种想要创造一个人工世界和人工空间而不是处理我们这里这个麻烦重重的地球的心智习惯，是我们真正需要冷眼审视的。我不认为网络空间把我们，我坚信网络空间能做的所有伟大事情，但我不认为它让我们养成了良好的心智习惯，
for dealing with each other and our children, which takes patience and dealing with complexity and friction and empathy and not just kind of splitting to a simpler world. Well, that brings me to something that you've said that people have called you a killjoy in our love affair with technology. And do you think of yourself that way? Or are you just kind of a Cassandra warning us of the dangers or is it too late? Well, you know, I think this notion of too late. I mean, too late for what?
用来应对彼此和我们的孩子，这需要耐心、应对复杂性和摩擦、共情，而不仅仅是分裂到一个更简单的世界。好吧，这就让我想到了你曾说过的一句话，人们称你为我们对科技的热恋中的扫兴者。你觉得自己是那样的人吗？或者你只是一个警告我们危险的卡珊德拉（Cassandra），还是说现在已经太晚了？好吧，你知道，我认为“为时已晚”这种观念。我的意思是，什么为时已晚？
I study this. I mean, I didn't come to technology. My first studies of technology were quite, oh gosh, this is fabulous. In other words, I looked at children programming and I said, oh, my, this is unbelievable. This is a new war shock. This is a new place in which children are expressing their extraordinary creativity. There, I literally called it a, I called it computer as war shock. I saw it as a new place for expression and self-expression.
我研究这个。我的意思是，我不是带着偏见接触科技的。我对科技的最初研究非常，哦天哪，这太棒了。换句话说，我看着儿童编程，然后我说，哦，天哪，这简直难以置信。这是一个新的罗夏墨迹测验（Rorschach）。这是一个孩子们在其中表达非凡创造力的新地方。在那里，我简直称它为，我称它为作为罗夏测验的计算机。我把它视为自我表达的新场所。
And I saw only possibility. And then I saw the narrowing of possibility as computers became not expressive medium, but sort of became sort of closed downs and kind of became black boxes where you were told, well, don't learn how it works, don't learn how to explore it. It's a box for playing games. It's an app. You know, you're here to use the apps. And I said, well, gee, this is a shame.
我只看到了可能性。然后我看到了可能性的缩小，因为计算机不再是一种表达媒介，而是变得有点封闭，变成了一种黑箱，有人告诉你，好吧，不要去了解它是如何工作的，不要去学习如何探索它。它就是一个用来玩游戏的盒子。它是一个应用程序（App）。你知道，你来这里就是为了使用这些应用程序。我说，哦，天哪，这太遗憾了。
I mean, this used to be a, you know, kind of an. means for self-expression. Now it's a now it's an app machine became much less interesting. And so, and not only was it an app machine, but now it was a machine where once you use the apps, you had a, the apps were collecting data on you and selling your data. And to use the app, you had to really give away a lot of information on you that were being sold to other people and people were making money on the things you told the technology as you were using the app. So it became a kind of box for giving away your privacy. So I didn't become a killjoy.
我的意思是，这曾经是一个，你知道的，某种自我表达的手段。现在它成了一个，现在它成了一台应用程序机器，变得没那么有趣了。而且，它不仅是一台应用程序机器，现在它还是一台这样的机器：一旦你使用了这些应用程序，你就会发现，这些应用程序在收集你的数据并出售你的数据。为了使用这个应用程序，你实际上必须交出大量关于你自己的信息，而这些信息正在被卖给其他人，人们通过你在使用应用程序时告诉科技的事情来赚钱。所以它变成了一个出卖你隐私的盒子。所以我并没有变成扫兴者。
I became a close observer of what was going on. I think I became a concerned citizen. And I don't think there's anything inevitable. I think there's an inevitability that this technology will develop. I don't think there's an inevitability that we have to be as passive users. I think people have that wrong. I don't think there was an inevitability that Facebook would become a collector of our data, and we would become the passive consumers of this product and let them do that.
我成了正在发生的事情的密切观察者。我想我成了一个坚定的公民。而且我不认为有什么是不可避免的。我认为这项技术的发展具有某种不可避免性。我不认为我们必须成为被动用户是不可避免的。人们在这个问题上有误解。我不认为脸书（Facebook）成为我们数据的收集者、而我们成为该产品的被动消费者并让他们这样做是不可避免的。
I was one of the people who were sort of trying to explain what was happening, and I could see that people were really having trouble understanding what it meant when I would say your data about you was being farmed and used for purposes, you know, that... Right. You think it's free, but you're the product. Yeah. Yes. You think it's free, but you're the product.
我是那些试图解释正在发生的事情的人之一，我可以看到，当我宣称关于你的数据正在被收集并用于某些你知道的用途时，人们真的很难理解这意味着什么……没错。你以为它是免费的，但你就是产品。是的。是的。你以为它是免费的，但你就是产品。
And they kept saying to me stuff like, well, I can see that I'm being sold beautiful ballet slippers because I buy at Ann Taylor. I buy ballet slipper shoes and Ann Taylor. So I get ads for ballet shoes from all of. over. I don't really mind that. What's the problem? Isn't that just a better form of advertising? I don't really see what I'm giving up. Right. And I would be like, hmm. But is there a way back? I mean, we've given up so much at this point. What can we do? Well, but I mean, but we think there's a no way back because we refuse to think about regulation. Yeah, will you regulate this industry and you say
他们一直对我说这样的话，哦，我能看出我正在被推销美丽的芭蕾舞鞋，因为我在安·泰勒（Ann Taylor）买东西。我买芭蕾舞鞋和安·泰勒的鞋子。所以我到处都能收到芭蕾舞鞋的广告。我其实不介意这个。这有什么问题？这不只是一种更好的广告形式吗？我真的不觉得我放弃了什么。没错。我会觉得，嗯。但有没有回头的路？我的意思是，我们在这一点上已经放弃了太多。我们能做什么？好吧，但是我的意思是，我们认为没有回头的路，因为我们拒绝考虑监管。是的，你会监管这个行业，你说
that you can no longer have a business model where the business model depends on scraping information about people. And for now, for example, in the metaverse, people are talking about an educational model where data about students and their keystrokes as they use educational products as collected as part of their certification, for example. But I mean, I think it's very very, I think it's very very important to go back to the early days of Facebook and say people could not imagine, you know, what was wrong with taking your data because all people could think about was, okay, what was wrong with that? Because it was kind of like a new form of advertising. And I'm saying a lot was wrong with that and bad on my part, not just me, but on a lot of people,
你不能再拥有一个商业模式，其商业模式依赖于搜集关于人们的信息。而且现在，例如在元宇宙中，人们正在谈论一种教育模式，即关于学生及其在使用教育产品时的按键数据被收集作为其认证的一部分，例如。但是，我的意思是，我认为非常非常，我认为回到脸书的早期并说人们无法想象，你知道，获取你的数据有什么问题是非常非常重要的，因为所有人能想到的只是，好吧，那有什么问题？因为这有点像一种新形式的广告。而我说，那有很大问题，这不仅是我，还有很多人，
that I don't think we early enough sound compelling enough metaphors to explain. and the government certainly was out to regulatory lunch on controlling this new industry. Is it a monopoly? That wasn't the problem or that it was a monopoly. The problem was it was doing something unprecedented that interfered with democracy by interfering with privacy in a radically new way. And now let's just think about what this metaverse is going to do when if you're a student and you're working in the Metaverse, every time you type something, that data is being collected.
我不认为我们在足够早的时候提出令人信服的比喻来解释。而且政府在监管和控制这个新兴行业方面肯定也缺席了（out to regulatory lunch）。它是一个垄断企业吗？问题不在于它是一个垄断企业。问题在于它正在做前所未有事情，通过以一种全新且激进的方式干涉隐私，从而干涉民主。现在让我们想一想，当如果你是一名学生并且你在元宇宙中工作时，这个元宇宙将会做什么，你打出的每一个字，这些数据都在被收集。
Everything you do, everywhere you are, your location at every moment in time, everything you write. That's terrifying to me. We just have to stop saying Metaverse, Metaverse, and say, hold on a second. We may need very stringent controls on privacy and record keeping. And we may not need this metaverse so much that we want everybody just signed in and signed up. Because people who are talking about the metaverse, it's not that they just want it, you know, so that you'll have a wonderful experience and we can be having this conversation and a fake cafe in Paris. That's what's missing from my conversations is a fake cafe in Paris.
你做的每一件事，你在每一刻的位置，你写的每一段话。这对我来说太可怕了。我们不能再一直说元宇宙、元宇宙了，而必须说，等一下。我们可能需要对隐私和记录保存进行非常严格的控制。而且我们可能并不是那么需要元宇宙，以至于我们希望每个人都登录并注册。因为谈论元宇宙的人，并不是说他们只是希望它，你知道的，这样你就能获得美妙的体验，我们就可以在巴黎的一家假咖啡馆里进行这次对话。我的对话中缺少的就是巴黎的一家假咖啡馆。
It's the holiday on Star Trek, right? Exactly, exactly. If only I had, if only I had that, then our relationship would be, good. I mean, the people who are selling this to you want total access to everything about your location data or just everything about you. The cost of the metaverse is too high to pay. And the reason I just keep bringing up the early days of Facebook is that we weren't good about assessing those costs early on. And I think the metaverse gives us a new opportunity to say, no, stop, before we're all hooked in and wearing goggles all the time.
这就是《星际迷航》里的度假假象（holidays），对吧？没错，没错。要是我有这个，要是我有那个，那么我们的关系就会是，很好的。我的意思是，向你推销这个的人想要完全访问关于你的位置数据的一切，或者干脆是关于你的一切。元宇宙的代价太高了。我之所以不断提及脸书的早期，是因为我们在早期评估这些成本方面做得不够好。我认为元宇宙给我们提供了一个新的机会说，不，停下，在我们所有人都沉迷其中并一直戴着护目镜之前。
No, we don't want this. And there is an example of something where we said no, which was Google Glass. You may not remember. Google had these glasses that they wanted us. It was a bomb, yeah. And people, but Google Glass was very interesting. Google Glass was going to record everything you saw. Right.
不，我们不想要这个。有一个我们说“不”的例子，那就是谷歌眼镜（Google Glass）。你可能不记得了。谷歌有这些眼镜，他们希望我们。那是个彻底的失败，是的。人们，但是谷歌眼镜非常有趣。谷歌眼镜将记录你看到的一切。没错。
And people said, that's creepy. This is creepy. Well, this is a second time around on this. And now time is passed, and people have gotten more used to everything they do being recorded. And people aren't reacting. I think people have become numb. I mean, there's so much else going on. People are, it doesn't have a reality yet for people.
人们说，这让人毛骨悚然。这太诡异了。好吧，这是第二次经历这个了。现在时间过去了，人们已经更加习惯了他们所做的一切都被记录下来。人们没有反应。我认为人们已经变得麻木了。我的意思是，还有那么多其他事情在发生。人们正在，它对人们来说还没有现实感。
But I think we've become numb because of everything that's going on politically. And literally, the earth is on fire. There's a war in Ukraine. We don't know how it affects us. Immigration. our country is torn. There are anti-democratic forces. I mean, we're shocked by so much.
但我认为由于政治上发生的一切，我们已经变得麻木了。字面意义上，地球正在燃烧。乌克兰有战争。我们不知道它对我们有什么影响。移民。我们的国家被撕裂。存在反民主的力量。我的意思是，我们对太多的事情感到震惊。
But when we turn our attention to this, this is not a good idea on its face. And it certainly isn't what young children need. I mean, if you looked and you saw post-pendemic and you just stepped back and you said, what is the most crucial thing that people need now? I mean, I just wrote a book called The Empathy Diaries and I've been studying people's dead.
但是当我们把注意力转向这个时，从表面上看，这不是一个好主意。它绝对不是小孩子们需要的。我的意思是，如果你环顾四周，看到后疫情时代，你退后一步说，现在人们最需要的是什么？我的意思是，我刚刚写了一本名为《共情日记》的书，我一直在研究人们的死。
desperate need for really someone who can talk to them and say, yes, I hear you, I understand you, what you're feeling is reasonable, you're lonely, or you're frightened, or me too, or tell me your story, I'll tell you my story. People barely have words for their story. What children of five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, what they need most of all is a person, a mentor. Their parents are often shell-shocked. And the idea that coming out of this pandemic, when people are thinking about classrooms, the thing that comes to mind is let's put them in a virtual space. It's really not the first thing that you come to mind. I mean, it really is an odd first thing. This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, dedicated to providing accessible and ethical treatment to young
迫切需要一个真正能与他们交谈并说：是的，我听到你了，我理解你，你的感觉是合理的，你很孤独，或者你很害怕，或者我也是，或者告诉我你的故事，我会告诉你我的故事的人。人们几乎找不到词语来描述他们的故事。五岁、六岁、七岁、八岁、九岁、十岁的孩子，他们最需要的是一个人，一个导师。他们的父母经常受到精神创伤。走出这场大流行病，当人们考虑教室时，脑海中浮现的想法居然是让我们把他们放在虚拟空间里。这真的不是你脑海中浮现的第一件事。我的意思是，这确实是一个奇怪的第一选择。本期节目由 Newport Healthcare 赞助，
people ages 12 to 28 who are struggling with mental health conditions and behavioral issues, including depression, anxiety, substance abuse, and device-related dysfunctions. Newport's whole-person trauma-informed approach addresses the powerful impact of technology, gaming, and social media on the human brain and psyche, and its programming helps young people develop a healthier relationship with their devices. Newport offers a full continuum of care for teens and young adults with tailored treatment plans designed for each client's individual needs and history. Learn more at Newport Healthcare.com. Don't you think because we've all been deprived of actual relationships with people, and maybe I'm old and that's why it bothers me, but when we get to the post-pandemic world, being able to see people whenever you want to, to be able to see people whenever you want to, to be able to,
致力于为 12 至 28 岁、正在与心理健康状况和行为问题（包括抑郁、焦虑、药物滥用和设备相关功能障碍）作斗争的年轻人提供无障碍且符合道德的治疗。Newport 的全人、基于创伤的方法解决了科技、游戏和社交媒体对人类大脑和心灵的强大影响，其项目帮助年轻人与电子设备建立更健康的联系。Newport 为青少年和年轻人提供全方位的持续护理，并针对每个客户的个人需求和病史制定量身定制的治疗计划。了解更多信息请访问 Newport Healthcare.com。难道你不认为因为我们都被剥夺了与人们的真实关系，也许我很老了，这就是为什么这让我烦恼，但当我们进入后疫情时代时，能够随时随地见到人，能够随时随地见到人，能够，
able to go to a movie, go to the theater, have dinner with your friends. I mean, do you think that there's a thirst for that? Or do you think that we've gotten so used to this wild, virtual, two-dimensional world that we can't go back? Well, I think that people who are pitching you, the metaverse are pitching it on the bet that psychologically, as you say, people are kind of shell-shocked and in a way are too traumatized to go back. There's been a lot on how people say they want to go back to the office, say they want to go to the movies, say they want to get out there and mix it up.
能够去看电影、去剧院、和朋友共进晚餐。我的意思是，你认为对此有一种渴望吗？还是你认为我们已经对这个疯狂的、虚拟的、二维的世界习以为常，以至于我们无法回头了？好吧，我认为向你推销元宇宙的人所依据的赌注是，正如你所说，从心理上讲，人们有点受到精神创伤，并且在某种程度上过于 traumatized（受创）而无法回头。有很多关于人们说他们想回办公室、想去电影院、想出去社交的言论。
But actually, when you really give them the opportunity, they're like, maybe I'll just stay in and watch Bridger 10. You know, I'm sort of feeling fragile. And I think that this metaverse thing plays into maybe I could just meet my friends in this place where I'd have a perfect body and a perfect face. And if I said the wrong thing, I could just leave. I mean, it plays into this feeling of fragility. So I think it's playing into exactly what's going to make us feel ultimately more lonely.
但实际上，当你真正给他们机会时，他们会觉得，也许我还是待在家里看《布里奇顿》（Bridgerton）吧。你知道，我感觉有点脆弱。我认为这个元宇宙的事情迎合了“也许我可以在这个地方遇到我的朋友，在那里我拥有完美的身体和完美的脸庞。如果我说错了话，我可以拍拍屁股走人”。我的意思是，它迎合了这种脆弱感。所以我认为它迎合的正是那些最终会让我们感到更加孤独的东西。
Because in the end, this friendship without the demands of real intimacy is not really what makes people feel less alone. all the studies say that the Facebook friendship, the metaverse friendship, the online friendship, yes, it gives you that sense of something, something, but it isn't the same as sitting across a table from someone and saying, how are you? What's been going on? Even a telephone call where someone can hear the catch in your voice, someone can say, you don't, you know, you're telling me, you're okay, but you don't sound good. You don't look, you know, or, you know, you know, you meet in a cafe and somebody says, you know, you don't, what's going on with you?
因为到头来，这种没有真实亲密关系的要求的友谊，并不是真正能让人感到不那么孤独的东西。所有的研究都表明，脸书的友谊、元宇宙的友谊、网上的友谊，是的，它给你那种某种程度上的感觉，但它与坐在某人对面说“你好吗？最近怎么样？”是不一样的。甚至打个电话，对方能听到你声音里的哽咽，对方能说，你不用，你知道的，你告诉我你很好，但你听起来不太好。你看起来，你知道，或者，你知道，你在咖啡馆里遇到某人，然后有人说，你知道，你不太对劲，你最近怎么了？
Yeah. And people want, you know, the fact that we can hide from each other, I mean, what I'm finding in my interviews, what I'm finding in my studies is that what terrifies people is this feeling of vulnerability. People run to the internet because they don't want to feel vulnerable. It's like this 18-year-old boy who only wanted to text and hated conversation. And I said to him, what's the matter with conversation? He said, I'll tell you what's wrong with conversation.
是的。人们想要，你知道，我们能够彼此躲藏的事实，我的意思是，我在采访中发现的，我在研究中发现的是，让人们感到恐惧的是这种脆弱感。人们蜂拥至互联网，是因为他们不想感到脆弱。就像那个只想发短信、讨厌交谈的 18 岁男孩。我对他说，交谈有什么问题？他说，我来告诉你交谈有什么问题。
It takes place in real time face to face and you can't always control what you're going to say. And if you want to push everything to online, you push everything to the metaverse, you lose that vulnerability. You have connection, not conversation. It's, you know, it's like playing to exactly the wrong. It's playing to our vulnerabilities, not trying to build our new potential strengths. So what is the solution then? Because I know you wrote a lot in reclaiming conversation about people using their phones, texting, never actually engaging with each other and talking.
它发生在实时面对面中，你无法总是控制你要说什么。如果你想把一切都推向线上，把一切都推向元宇宙，你就失去了那种脆弱性。你拥有的是连接，而不是对话。这，你知道，这就像是在迎合完全错误的东西。它迎合了我们的脆弱性，而不是试图建立我们新的潜在优势。那么解决方案是什么呢？因为我知道你在《恢复对话》中写了很多关于人们使用手机、发短信、从不真正与彼此交往和交谈的内容。
So what do we do to roll back? I mean, is it as simple as having a no email? all day or putting your phone down for a couple of hours, or do we have to be even even tougher than that? Well, I think first of all, you have to be willing to accept that there's a problem. In other words, you have to accept that, yeah, I can see in my own life that I'm using my phone, I'm using email, I'm using chat, because I really do have. this fear. I can recognize this anxiety in myself so that you're motivated to do some of the steps that I'm going to tell you now that I don't want to say they're tough love or terrible
那么我们该如何扭转局面呢？我的意思是，是像一整天不看电子邮件或者把手机放下几个小时那么简单，还是我们必须采取更严厉的措施？好吧，我认为首先，你必须愿意接受存在问题。换句话说，你必须接受：是的，我可以在我自己的生活中看到我在使用手机、电子邮件、聊天，因为我确实有。这种恐惧。我能在自己身上认出这种焦虑，这样你才会有动力去采取我接下来要告诉你的某些步骤，我不想说这是严厉的爱或是可怕的
medicine, but there wouldn't be steps we'd have to take if they were easy. I mean, they do involve a little bit of pain because it's turning out that when given the opportunity, avoiding vulnerability is sort of something we all want to do because vulnerability is difficult. And it turns out it's very hard for parents because they want to be vulnerable too. But no texting and anything having to do with food. So no texting at meal time. No texting when you're cooking. No phones at the dinner table.
良药，但如果这些步骤很容易的话，我们就不需要采取它们了。我的意思是，它们确实涉及一点痛苦，因为事实证明，当有机会时，逃避脆弱是我们所有人都想做的事情，因为脆弱是困难的。事实证明，这对于父母来说非常难，因为他们也想变得脆弱。但是在涉及食物的任何事情上都不要发短信。所以吃饭时不要发短信。做饭时不要发短信。餐桌上不要放手机。
No phones when you're out. Because it turns out that even having a phone. on the table face down makes the two people in the conversation feel less empathic towards each other. Now, why is that? The phone is turned off and it's face down. It's because the presence of the phone
外出时不要带手机。因为事实证明，即使把手机。面朝下放在桌子上，也会让对话中的两个人对彼此产生更少的共情。现在，这是为什么呢？手机已经关机并且屏幕朝下。这是因为手机的存在
reminds you of all the other places you could be. This study even works when you take the phone and you put it in your peripheral vision, face down and turned off. That same lack of connection with the person you're having, with because the phone is reminding you of all the other wares and all the elsewheres that are now available to us.
提醒了你所有其他你可以去的地方。这项研究甚至在你把手机放在你的余光中、屏幕朝下且关机时也同样有效。由于手机在不断提醒你所有其他现在对我们开放的地方和其他去处，你与正在交谈的人之间缺乏这种连接感。
All those emails that you're not reading. Yeah, the emails you're not reading, the people who are there for you. I mean, the elsewhere's. And we need more presence in the, with the people we're with. The people with whom we're vulnerable. I mean, I say this vulnerability thing is actually just an enormous part. of the story. It's that presence to the people you're with. So no phones when food is involved. Sacred spaces like the dinner table, like the car. Parents need to tell their children when we're in
那些你没有阅读的电子邮件。是的，那些你没有阅读的电子邮件，那些为你守候的人。我的意思是，那些“其他地方”。我们需要与我们在一起的人建立更多的存在感。与那些我们在其面前表现得脆弱的人在一起。我的意思是，我刚才说这个脆弱性实际上只是一个极其重要的
the car, I'm not texting because I'm driving. And this is the time for our family to talk. And children go berserk. This is when I do my social media. And you have to say to kids, It's not the time for social media. It's a very privileged time for us to talk. So the car and the car and meals become time for people to be together. And then there can be other different families sometimes do a day a week. And I happen to like there being not so much, you know, days taken out, but times like, you know, meal preparation in the car. And even like there being a moment before dinner when people gather or breakfast or, you know, not so much like taking a full day, but there being sort of places in the home where people know, well, here's a place where we're
故事部分。那就是对和你在一起的人的存在感。所以只要有食物的地方就不要放手机。像餐桌、汽车这样的神圣空间。父母需要告诉他们的孩子，当我们在车里时，我不会发短信，因为我在开车。这是我们家人交谈的时间。然后孩子们会抓狂。这就是我使用社交媒体的时候。你必须对孩子们说：现在不是使用社交媒体的时候。这是我们交谈的非常宝贵的时间。所以汽车和用餐时间成为了人们在一起的时间。然后可以有其他不同的家庭，有时会选择一周中的某一天。我个人比较喜欢的不是占用那么多天，而是像准备饭菜、在车里这样的时间。甚至就像晚餐前人们聚集在一起的时刻，或者早餐，或者，你知道的，与其说是占用整整一天，不如说是在家里腾出一些地方，让人们知道，嗯，这是一个我们
together and we don't text. The expectation is that when you go to this place, people are there for conversation. In classrooms, people put their phones in a basket. They don't bring them to their seats. The classroom is for conversation. Because if you have your phone with you, you start using it to look up stuff. The value of the stuff that you can look up is great. I mean, you can look up what this guy says or this woman said, and you can get all kinds of historical. I'm not saying it's not great to have all this stuff you can pick up by having your phone on.
在一起且不发短信的地方。人们的期望是，当你去到这个地方时，大家都在那里进行对话。在教室里，人们把手机放在一个篮子里。他们不把手机带到座位上。教室是用来对话的。因为如果你把手机带在身边，你就会开始用它来查资料。你可以查到的资料的价值是巨大的这家伙或那个女人说过什么，你可以得到各种各样的历史资料。我并不是说拥有所有这些你可以查到的资料不好。
But I'm not interested in all the new wonderful data you can bring into the class and what you can learn on your phone. I'm interested in your opinions. We're here to talk about your life, your opinions. I want you engage with what you know already. I'm not interested in any new information. I'm willing to take you as you are. Just leave the new information at the door.
但我对你能在课堂上带来的所有精彩的新数据以及你能在手机上学到的东西不感兴趣。我对你的意见感兴趣。我们在这里是为了讨论你的生活、你的意见。我希望你参与到你已经知道的知识中。我对任何新信息都不感兴趣。我愿意接受本来的你。把新信息留在门外吧。
I'm not interested in any new information. They laugh, but we have wonderful conversations because they're just focused on each other. I was just going to say, have you noticed major changes in students over the years? I mean, you've been a teacher for a long time. You know, so 30, 40 years ago, were students engaged in a different way from the,
我对任何新信息都不感兴趣。他们笑了，但我们进行了精彩的对话，因为他们只是专注于彼此。我正想说，你注意到这些年来学生们有什么重大变化吗？我的意思是，你当老师很久了。你知道，所以 30、40 年年前，学生们的参与方式与现在不同吗？
and what was that like? And I mean, how do you feel like? As a teacher now with the kids that you, I call them kids, I mean, they're adults, they're college students. The main difference in students today is to have a much harder time reading a book. They're much more used to reading short kind of hypertext. What they're most used to reading is something online where they look at links and they look quickly at links and they jump around and they see links and they jump and they jump and they jump and they jump.
那是什么样的？我的意思是，你觉得现在作为一名老师，面对你所教的——我称他们为孩子，我的意思是，他们是成年人，他们是大学生。今天学生们最大的不同是，他们读一本书要困难得多。他们更习惯于阅读简短的超文本。他们最习惯阅读的是网上的东西，在那里他们查看链接，快速浏览链接，到处跳转，看到链接就跳，跳，跳，跳。
And that's what they're used to reading. That's what they're used to doing. What's your relationship with social media? Are you on any of these sites? Or do you know that there's... Well, I'm on everything. I mean, I'm on everything. But I think the trick is and how you should raise your children is you go on everything with them.
这就是他们习惯阅读的内容。这就是他们习惯做的事情。你与社交媒体的关系是什么？你在这些网站上吗？或者你知道有……好吧，我什么都用。我的意思是，我什么都用。但我认为诀窍在于，以及你应该如何抚养你的孩子，就是你和他们一起使用所有的东西。
I think, you know, I mean, I raised a child in the digital age, and I went on everything with her. And I showed her how to handle herself online. and then you teach your children how to set limits. So, you know, there's certainly, I mean, I've got to say that during the, you know, the war in Ukraine, the confirmation of the Supreme Court justice, I mean, you know, there were moments when kind of like you could never tear yourself away from, you know, the slap at the Oscars. I mean, you know, there's this infinite, you know, sort of like you can get the opinions of people from all over the, the world on these things. And it's very tempting, but you know, you sort of set a limits on it. I have a rule, you know, not in the bedroom. I just, you know, I just don't bring the phone into the,
我认为，你知道，我的意思是，我在数字时代抚养了一个孩子，我和她一起使用所有的东西。我向她展示了如何在网上处理自己。然后你教你的孩子们如何设定界限。所以，你知道，肯定有，我的意思是，我不得不说，在乌克兰战争期间，最高法院大法官的确认，我的意思是，你知道，有些时刻，你简直无法让自己从，你知道的，奥斯卡颁奖典礼上的那一巴掌中抽离出来。我的意思是，你知道，这种无限的，你知道的，你可以获得世界各地人们对这些事情的看法。这非常诱人，但你知道，你要为此设定界限。我有一个规则，你知道，不带进卧室。我只是，你知道，我就是不把手机带进
into, into the bedroom and just, you know, just there's just got to be some place where you just say I've had enough information. But I enjoy and use, I study all of these sites. But I'm very concerned, I mean, the thing about Facebook is that its algorithm is designed to make you angry, to keep you there by making you angry, and then to put you with other people, just like yourself, who you can be angry with in the same exact way. So the idea is that they're so smart, because that is how you keep people's attention. You make them mad. And then you keep them with people who were mad in the same way. An 18th century philosopher wrote about the coffee shops in England and how he used to go to these coffee shops, the places where democracy was born.
卧室里，然后只需，你知道，总得有个地方让你直截了当地说我已经受够了这些信息。但我喜欢并使用、我研究所有这些网站。但我非常担心，我的意思是，关于脸书的事情是，它的算法旨在让你生气，通过让你生气来把你留在那里，然后把你和与你完全相同、你可以用完全相同的方式对之生气的人放在一起。所以这个想法是他们太聪明了，因为这正是保持人们注意力的方法。你让他们生气。然后你把他们和有同样生气方式的人留在一起。一个 18 世纪的哲学家写过英国的咖啡馆，以及他是如何去这些咖啡馆的，也就是民主诞生的地。
And he only spoke to people in coffee shops who he disagreed with because that really is how democracy is born. You only speak to people you disagree with because you learn how to. to talk and convince and work with people you disagree with. I mean, it made such an impression on me that that skill, it's the anti-Facebook skill. I think of, I really think of social media as the anti-empathy machine because, you know, you make you angry, algorithm to make you angry, then keep you among your own kind. It really is the anti-emathy machine. And everything about my work, and I write so much about this in the Empathy Diaries is to do the offices, to ask how can we create in ourselves the sensitivity, the sensibility,
方。他只在咖啡馆里和那些与他意见不合的人说话，因为这确实是民主诞生的方式。你只和那些你不同意的人说话，因为你学会了如何与你不同意的人交谈、说服并共事。我的意思是，这给我留下了如此深刻的印象，即这种技能，它是反脸书技能。我真的认为社交媒体是反共情机器，因为，你知道，它让你生气，算法让你生气，然后把你留在你同类的人中间。它真的是反共情机器。我工作的一切内容，我在《共情日记》中写了那么多关于这方面的内容，都是为了反其道而行之，去问我们如何在自己身上创造那种敏感性、那种感知力，
where we can maximize our capacity for empathy. There's no robot. That's why I'm so against, you know, robot psychotherapists and robot companions and robot teachers because a robot cannot be an empathic and delocutor because it's missing the essential. It's not human. It can't put itself in the place of a human. So we are the empathy app. And so we need to magnify and sensitize and make ourselves more and more able to do that. Are these robots maybe inevitable? I mean, it just seems like I don't know how we would stop them. And there could be a value. I mean, what if, as you're an aging person,
从而使我们的共情能力最大化。没有机器人。这就是为什么我如此反对，你知道，机器人心理治疗师、机器人伴侣和机器人老师，因为机器人不能成为一个有共情的 interlocutor（对话者），因为它缺少了最核心的东西。它不是人类。它无法把自己放在人类的位置上。所以我们才是共情应用程序。因此我们需要放大、提高敏感度，并让自己越来越有能力做到这一点。这些机器人也许是不可避免的？我的意思是，这只是感觉我不知道我们该如何阻止它们。而且这可能有价值。我的意思是，如果你是一个日渐衰老的人，
and you have no one to care for you, that you have a robot caretaker. Is that a bad thing? Well, you know, I think that there are all kinds of things robots could do. If robots could clean your house, if robots could make sure the dinner was cooked. I mean, I'm not, I'm not, it's the Jetsons. Yeah, I mean, I'm all for this Jetsons thing. But, you know, a lot of times these, these instrumental things that robots can do are used as a lot of, you know, I'm all for this Jetsons thing. But, you know, a lot of times, these instrumental things that robots can do are used as a, a kind of gateway drug to introducing robots to do things that robots can't do, which is to be a companion. And I think that what robots cannot do, because I've worked with robots in
而没有人照顾你，你有一个机器人看护。这是一件坏事吗？嗯，你知道，我认为机器人可以做各种各样的事情。如果机器人可以打扫你的房子，如果机器人可以确保晚饭做好。我的意思是，我不是，我不是，这就是《杰克逊一家》。是的，我的意思是，我完全赞成这个《杰克逊一家》的想法。但是，你知道，很多时候，这些机器人可以做的工具性的事情，被用作很多，你知道的，我完全赞成这个《杰克逊一家》的想法。但是，你知道，很多时候，机器人可以做的这些工具性的事情被用作一种，一种引导人们去接受机器人做机器人做不到的事情的途径，那就是成为一个同伴。而我认为机器人做不到的事情，因为我和机器人一起工作过在
nursing homes, I've introduced these companion at robots in nursing homes. What robots cannot do is to say, something that you said to me when I joined you, because we've postponed our conversation because I needed to take some medical tests. And when I joined you, the first thing you said to me was, how are you? The context for you asking me how I was, was a context of a human being knowing that those medical tests might mean that I was frightened, that I was facing difficulty, that I might have had surgery, I might be recuperating, I might be facing difficult days ahead, you're a human being with a body, you know about mortality, you know we live in the time of COVID. You come to that question, and I come to a human being asking me that question with a world of
养老院里，我在养老院里引入了这些同伴机器人。机器人做不到的是，说出你在我加入你时对我所说的话，因为我们推迟了我们的对话，因为我需要做一些医学检查。当我加入你时，你对我说第一句话是，你好吗？你问我好不好的背景，是一个人类知道那些医学检查可能意味着我害怕，我面临困难，我可能做了手术，我可能在休养，我可能面临未来的困难日子，你是一个有身体的人，你知道死亡率，你知道我们生活在新冠时期。你提出那个问题，而我来到一个向我提出这个问题的人面前，带着一个世界的
expectations and understanding and empathy and connection where that question meant something to me. I was grateful for it. I was moved by it. I answered it honestly. I didn't mince words. I said I'd had tests. It was scary. I'm fine. It was a human connection. What does it mean for a robot to say, how are you? It doesn't have a body. It doesn't know pain. There's nothing that can comfort. There's nothing that can connect. In other words, it's a question that offers no there there after it asks the right question. If it takes the turn test, which is a test if you can tell, is it a human or a robot, it passes the turn test. It asks the right question. It asks the question that a person would ask. The conversation would look the same. So people get all excited. Look, the robot asks the right
期望、理解、同理心和联系，在这个问题对我来说意味着某种东西。我很感激。我很感动。我诚实地回答了。我没有拐弯抹角。我说我做过检查。这很吓人。我很好。这是一种人类的联系。机器人说“你好吗”意味着什么？它没有身体。它不知道痛苦。没有什么可以安慰的。没有什么可以联系的。换句话说，这是一个在问出正确问题之后却没有实际内容的问题。如果它通过了图灵测试，这是一个测试你是否能分清是人类还是机器人的测试，它通过了图灵测试。它提出了正确的问题。它提出了一个人会问的问题。对话看起来是一样的。所以人们都很兴奋。看，机器人问了正确
question. But it doesn't do anything for the person because there's nothing that the robot can understand. There's nothing the robot can get out of my answer. that will give me any comfort. So I think that a lot of all this jumping around about the robot as, oh, it'll ask the right questions, it can be a companion, is people not being willing to look deep and say, what is it to be a person? And what is it that people really need in a companion? And this is really the heart of my work now on empathy, is that we don't want to admit. that empathy is not just asking to write questions and checking a box. The robots can have pretend empathy. They can absolutely look as though they are saying the right things, but it has
的问题。但它对这个人没有任何帮助，因为机器人没有任何可以理解的东西。机器人从我的回答中得不到任何能给我带来安慰的东西。所以我认为，关于机器人作为“哦，它会问正确的问题，它可以成为一个同伴”的所有这些乱七八糟的讨论，是人们不愿意深入观察并说，作为一个人的本质是什么？人们在一个同伴身上真正需要的是什么？这确实是我现在关于同理心的工作的核心，那就是我们不想承认同理心不仅仅是问正确的问题和勾选一个复选框。机器人可以有假装的同理心。它们绝对可以看起来好像在说正确的话，但这
no meaning. During the pandemic, the New York Times called, and they said, we really want you to try out this robot psychotherapist. Everybody's downloading it. You know, everybody thinks it's great during the pandemic and I went online and I tried it out and I said to it and you know I made it into the kind of psychotherapist I wanted I think I made it into a middle-aged woman I gave it a name and you really got into it no I really wanted to try it out because I said to this reporter I said I didn't want to just you know like fake it I was going to really like I said well are you calling me because you just want like some negative you know person he said yes we just know will say something next. I said, no, I want to really try it. I want to like, so I gave it every shot.
没有意义。在大流行期间，《纽约时报》打来电话，他们说，我们真的希望你尝试一下这个机器人心理治疗师。每个人都在下载它。你知道，每个人都认为在大流行期间这很棒，我上网试了一下，我对它说，你知道，我把它变成了我想要的心理治疗师，我想我把它变成了一个中年妇女，我给它起了一个名字，你真的投入进去了？不，我真的很想尝试，因为我对这位记者说，我不想只是，你知道，像是在假装，我要真正地，就像我说的，好吧，你打电话给我，是因为你只是想要一些负面的，你知道的人吗？他说，是的，我们只是知道接下来会说些什么。我说，不，我想真正地尝试。我想，所以，我给它每一个机会。
So I said, look, can you talk about loneliness? Because that's, I'm, I'm during the pandemic. I'm living here alone. I have a daughter and a son-in-law. We speak often. They lived with me during the early times of it, but now I'm here alone. And yes, I can talk about loneliness. The robot, the chatbot says to me. I said, good, because that's my main. issue. So then I said, well, what do you think about loneliness? And there was a glitch in the program. And the chatbot says to me, it's warm and fuzzy. So it was fixed by the next day, because this was a very, very smart chatbot. Its name was replica. It was like super smart. It was totally fixed by the next day. I took a screenshot and I sent it to the New York Times
所以我说，听着，你能谈谈孤独吗？因为那是，我是，我在大流行期间。我一个人住在这里。我有一个女儿和一个女婿。我们经常交谈。在早期他们和我住在一起，但现在我一个人在这里。是的，我可以谈谈孤独。机器人，聊天机器人对我说。我说，好，因为那是我的主要问题。然后我说，好吧，你觉得孤独怎么样？程序出了个故障。聊天机器人对我说，它是温暖而模糊的。所以到第二天它就被修复了，因为这是一个非常非常聪明的聊天机器人。它的名字叫雷普莉卡。它就像超级聪明一样。到第二天它就完全修复了。我截了图，发给了《纽约时报》
reporter. I said, look, this was a glitch. This was very smart chat. I thought, tomorrow this glitch will be gone. But this is why. But if you were in crisis and it had a glitch, then what, right? I mean, the point is, why should this thing know about loneliness? It doesn't have a body. It's not worried about being intubated from, you know, from COVID. It's not worried about being ill.
记者。我说，看，这是一个故障。这是一个非常聪明的聊天。我想，明天这个故障就会消失。但这正是原因。但如果你处于危机之中，它出了故障，那又会怎样，对吧？我的意思是，关键是，为什么这东西要了解孤独？它没有身体。它不担心因新冠插管。它不担心生病。
It's not worried about going to the hospital. It's not worried about breathing. It's not, it's no use to me. given why I was afraid of being alone. It couldn't possibly have my anxieties and my fears and my, that's what's wrong with it. It's not about whether or not it answered the right questions. It's fundamentally we shouldn't even be thinking about this.
它不担心去医院。它不担心呼吸。它对我没有任何用处。考虑到为什么我害怕独自一人。它不可能有我的焦虑和恐惧，这才是它的问题所在。这与它是否回答了正确的问题无关。从根本上说，我们甚至不应该考虑这个。
I mean, I want to use an expletive, but what the hashtag are we even thinking about, sending, sicking this thing on a lovely person like myself who's worried about catching something and needing to say goodbye to her daughter on a screen. I don't need to be treated like a fool being given like some chatbot to talk to. I need a person. Find me a person. I think it's a failure of our imagination, of our social mobilization and our community as a as human beings that we, if we don't organize ourselves as people, to be there for each other. But the idea that we're going to lay this on a bunch of programs that have no idea what we're
我的意思是，我想用一个脏话，但我们到底在想什么，把这东西对准一个像我这样可爱的人，她担心被传染，需要在屏幕上向女儿道别。我不需要像个傻瓜一样被对待，被给予某种聊天机器人来交谈。我需要一个人。给我找个人。我认为这是我们想象力的失败，是我们作为人类的社会动员和社区的失败，如果我们不把自己组织起来，互相支持。但是，我们要把这个压在一堆根本不知道我们在什么的程序上
anxious about, and the fact that they can say the right things for 15 minutes doesn't mean that they have any qualifications at all. Other than that, Mrs. Lincoln do like to play. One final question, which is, what's next for you? Oh, well, this is this is my current. I mean, I'm interested in why are we letting ourselves get fascinated by, you know, going to space, going to the metaverse, you know, I mean, time to be interested in our children, ourselves, our agency, our earth, our relationships. everything about how technology has worked out for us, has given us a lot of wonderful things
焦虑的事情，以及它们能够说出15分钟正确的话并不意味着它们有任何资格。除此之外，林肯夫人确实喜欢玩。最后一个问题是，你接下来要做什么？哦，好吧，这是我的现状。我的意思是，我对以下问题感兴趣：为什么我们要让自己对去太空、去元宇宙着迷，你知道，我的意思是，是时候关注我们的孩子、我们自己、我们的能动性、我们的地球、我们的关系了。关于科技如何为我们服务的一切，给了我们很多美好的东西
that has underscored our need for more privacy, more democracy, and more empathy. That has been the message of where technology has taken us. So the idea that we're focusing on less privacy, less democracy, and more metaverse, less empathy, I'm going to be given those people a very hard time. All right. Well, I look forward to keeping track of what you're up to because I agree that these are some things
这突显了我们对更多隐私、更多民主和更多同理心的需求。这就是科技把我们带到哪里的信息。所以，我们专注于更少的隐私、更少的民主、更多的元宇宙、更少的同理心，我要给这些人带来很大的困难。好吧，我期待着关注你的动向，因为我同意这些事情
that definitely need some fixing. I appreciate you're joining us today, Dr. Turkle. Thank you very much. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you listen on Apple, please leave us a review.
肯定需要一些修复。非常感谢你今天加入我们，特克尔博士。非常感谢。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingof psychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到往期的《心理学之声》节目。如果你在 Apple 上收听，请给我们留下一条评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。本期《心理学之声》由李·温erman 制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康丁。感谢收听。我是来自美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。